My grandfather, Melvin, ran a hardware store in Baltimore that also sold model trains. And he had a huge-- and I mean huge-- train set in the basement of his house on Pimlico Road that I loved. This thing was vast, with tunnels and bridges and towns and streetlights that lit. And the train engines puff smoke as they scooted around the track on this big, wooden platform in the basement in the middle of all this epic amount of clutter and junk and his tools and, for some reason, a mimeograph machine.
我祖父梅尔文（Melvin）在巴尔的摩经营一家五金店，同时也卖火车模型。他在皮姆利科路（Pimlico Road）家中的地下室里有一个巨大的——我是说真的巨大——火车模型，我非常喜欢。这套模型非常广阔，有隧道、桥梁、城镇和会发光的街灯。火车头在地下室那块巨大的木制平台上绕着轨道行驶时还会喷出烟雾，而周围堆满了各种极其杂乱的破烂、他的工具，以及不知为何放在那儿的一台油印机。
And in the corner of the basement was the filthiest toilet I had ever seen-- like, frighteningly dirty to me as a little suburban kid. The whole basement was a chamber of chaos, and it was the most unsettlingly-chaotic thing in it. But that is not the story I'm here to tell. The story I'm here to tell is about Melvin and one of his sisters.
地下室的角落里还有我见过最脏的厕所——作为一个郊区长大的小孩，我觉得它脏得吓人。整个地下室就像一个混乱的巢穴，而那个厕所是其中最让人不安、最混乱的东西。但这并不是我要讲的故事。我要讲的是关于梅尔文和他其中一个姐妹的故事。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Uncle Bennett?
本内特（Bennett）叔叔？
Yes, you got it.
没错，是我。
To be sure I was getting the facts absolutely right on this thing, I called the last person in the family who might remember it, my Uncle Bennett. He was at home.
为了确保我了解的事实绝对准确，我打电话给了家里唯一可能还记得这件事的人，我的本内特叔叔。他当时在家。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃声]
Wait a minute. Hold on for one second.
等一下。稍微等一下。
Yeah, well do.
好的，没问题。
Yeah, yeah. Hello? Hello? Yeah, Renee?
好了，好了。喂？喂？哦，蕾妮（Renee）吗？
Renee is Bennett's girlfriend. They live together.
蕾妮是本内特的女朋友。他们住在一起。
That was Renee. She wasn't sure if I was home.
刚才那是蕾妮。她不确定我是不是在家。
Ah.
啊。
All right, anyway--
好吧，总之——
Wait, wait. Is she in the house and she called you?
等等，等等。她在屋里，然后她打电话给你？
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
对。对。对。
I guess you're getting this-- these are older people who do not want to be bothered to cross the house or yell from room to room. Anyway, the story-- the story that I'm here to tell about my grandfather, Melvin, and his brothers and sisters.
我想你大概明白了——这些上了年纪的人不想费劲走过整个屋子，也不想隔着房间大喊大叫。总之，故事——我要讲关于我祖父梅尔文和他兄弟姐妹的故事。
Let me just give you the family geography here. He's one of four kids. And for the purposes of this particular story, you should imagine them in two competing teams. There are the two older kids, Melvin and Dorothy, and the two younger kids, Ray and Calvin.
让我先给你梳理一下家庭成员结构。他是四个孩子中的一个。为了讲好这个故事，你应该把他们想象成两支竞争的队伍。年纪大的两个是梅尔文和多萝西（Dorothy），年纪小的两个是雷（Ray）和卡尔文（Calvin）。
OK, Melvin and Dorothy, Ray and Calvin. It's 1964, and their mom dies. The four kids are all in their 40s and 50s at this point. And then just after she died--
好的，梅尔文和多萝西，雷和卡尔文。那是1964年，他们的母亲去世了。当时这四个孩子都已经四五十岁了。就在她去世后——
What happened was, Ray came up from Florida. And Calvin and Ray started taking things out of the house-- the silver tea service I remember that she had in the dining room. Whatever she had of value, they took.
发生的事情是，雷从佛罗里达州回来了。接着卡尔文和雷开始把家里的东西往外搬——我记得她餐厅里有套银质茶具。凡是值钱的东西，他们全拿走了。
And there was china, right? Like, the thing that I had always heard is that there was china and silverware.
还有瓷器，对吧？我一直听说的就是有瓷器和银器。
Yeah, china, silverware, things like that. They just came in like hordes of locusts. And my father got nothing. And Dorothy apparently allegedly got nothing.
对，瓷器、银器之类的。他们简直像蝗虫大军一样冲进来。我父亲什么都没得到。多萝西显然据说也没得到任何东西。
Again, the two older kids-- Melvin and Dorothy. The younger kids, Calvin and Ray, took all the good stuff.
再次强调，两个年长的孩子——梅尔文和多萝西。两个小的，卡尔文和雷，拿走了所有好东西。
And then my father was really upset about it.
然后我父亲对此非常难过。
Yeah. And Dorothy too, right?
没错。还有多萝西，对吧？
Yeah, mm-hmm.
对，嗯。
This, Bennett explained to me, was apparently typical behavior for Ray.
本内特向我解释说，这在雷身上是很典型的行为。
Ray was always-- like, when she was growing up, they used to say that at dinner, she would take the biggest piece of meat.
雷一直都是这样——就像她小时候，大家都说在吃晚饭时，她会抢最大块的肉。
Yeah, yeah. And then the way I remember it is that she takes the stuff, they fight about it, and they never spoke to Ray again.
对，没错。然后我记得的是，她拿走了东西，他们为此吵了一架，从此再也没和雷说过话。
No.
没有。
Didn't talk to her, didn't talk about her.
没再理她，也没再提起她。
No, it was just too aggravating, you know?
没有，这太让人恼火了，你知道吗？
Calvin, meanwhile-- Ray's partner in this family heist-- Calvin was a baby in the family, 13 years younger than the next-oldest kid. And the way that I always heard it, nobody held this against Calvin because everybody knew that Ray could just push him around and get him to do whatever she wanted.
与此同时，卡尔文——雷在这个家族掠夺案中的同伙——卡尔文是家里的老幺，比前面那个小了13岁。我一直听到的说法是，没人怪罪卡尔文，因为大家都知道雷可以随意指使他，让他做任何她想做的事。
So Calvin was around. I remember Calvin clowning around, doing little magic tricks for me at charity crab feasts that Dorothy used to organize all through my childhood.
所以卡尔文还在家里。我记得卡尔文经常搞怪，在多萝西我童年时期组织的慈善螃蟹宴上，他会为我变些小魔术。
But not Ray. It really was like Ray never existed, was never spoken about, off in Florida. I and my sisters met her only one time. Bennett, her own nephew-- Bennett only met her once on a trip to Miami after he was married.
但雷不是。真的就像雷从未存在过一样，没人提起她，她远在佛罗里达。我和我的姐妹们只见过她一次。本内特，她自己的侄子——本内特也是在他结婚后去迈阿密旅行时才见过她一次。
And I called Ray. And she and Uncle Irvin came up, picked us up, and took us to Wolfie's-- [COUGH] pardon me-- which is a deli restaurant.
我给雷打了电话。她和欧文（Irvin）叔叔来接我们，带我们去了沃尔菲（Wolfie's）——[咳嗽]抱歉——那是一家熟食餐厅。
Yeah.
对。
That was the only contact I ever had with her my whole life.
那是我一生中和她唯一的接触。
And then I remember when Melvin died, Ray not coming to his funeral.
然后我记得梅尔文去世时，雷没有来参加他的葬礼。
No, of course not.
不，当然没有。
And I remember being so stunned by that, that a person could be in such a fight with their own sibling that they wouldn't show up at their funeral.
我记得当时非常震惊，一个人竟然能和自己的亲兄弟姐妹闹到这种地步，连葬礼都不出席。
Oh, it happens all the time, Ira. And it's usually over money.
哦，这种事经常发生，艾拉（Ira）。通常都是为了钱。
I think this story really got to me when I was a kid, and I first heard it because it was the very first glimpse I had at the idea that you can destroy things completely-- like, totally wreck them beyond repair-- with somebody you know so well. I mean, I guess I'm lucky that I lived in a family where something like this would be so rare. But still, for me, personally, that has been a hard lesson to hold on to.
我想这个故事在我小时候第一次听到时就深深触动了我，因为那是我第一次窥见这样一个事实：你可以彻底摧毁一些东西——我是说，彻底毁掉且无法修复——哪怕是和你非常熟悉的人之间。我是说，我想我很幸运能生活在一个这种事很少见的家庭。但即便如此，对我个人而言，这仍然是一个难以接受的惨痛教训。
When I was married and things were going badly and we were in counseling and trying to patch it together for so many years-- like, more years than I want to admit here on the radio-- and I think part of it was because I just had this feeling, like, we are not people who get divorced. Like, we are bigger than that somehow. My mom was a marriage therapist. I just couldn't accept-- I think we both couldn't accept-- that we had just broken things between us so badly that there was no coming back from it.
当我结婚后，情况开始变糟，我们做了很多年的心理咨询试图挽救这段婚姻——比我在广播里愿意承认的时间还要长——我想部分原因是我有一种感觉，觉得我们不是那种会离婚的人。我们某种程度上比这更重要。我母亲是婚姻治疗师。我就是无法接受——我想我们俩都无法接受——我们之间已经把事情搞砸到了无法挽回的地步。
I just didn't want to admit that-- which brings me to Humpty Dumpty. I didn't know this, but some of my coworkers with little kids at home were talking about how unsettling Humpty Dumpty is to some of those kids. Laura said that at the doctor's office, there's a poster. And their two-year-old saw it and after that was like, someone can break and not go back together? And then remembered it when they went back to that office a year later.
我只是不想承认这一点——这让我想到了矮胖子（Humpty Dumpty）。我之前不知道，但几个有小孩的同事聊到矮胖子对一些孩子来说有多么令人不安。劳拉（Laura）说在医生办公室里有一张海报。她两岁的孩子看到了，在那之后就一直在问：一个人破碎了就不能再拼好了吗？一年后他们再去那间办公室时，孩子还记得这件事。
Zoe's son, Max, is two and a half.
佐伊（Zoe）的儿子马克斯（Max）两岁半。
I want to tell him to go back together.
我想告诉他把它拼回去。
You want it to go back together?
你想让它复原吗？
Yeah, to fix it.
对，把它修好。
You want to fix Humpty Dumpty?
你想修好矮胖子？
Yeah. I cannot do it.
对。我做不到。
We posted a thing on social media about this and got a ton of responses from parents whose kids were terrified of Humpty Dumpty. One said her preschooler couldn't stand to see her crack eggs in the kitchen because it reminded her of the nursery rhyme. Another said her two-year-old spent weeks asking if he could recreate the story with an egg from the fridge, which they did-- like, a few times-- puzzling over the impossibility of putting an egg back together once it's cracked.
我们在社交媒体上发了关于这个话题的内容，收到了大量家长的反馈，他们的孩子都被矮胖子吓坏了。一位母亲说，她上学前的孩子在厨房看到她敲鸡蛋时都受不了，因为这让她想起了那首童谣。另一位说，她两岁的孩子花了几个星期问能不能用冰箱里的鸡蛋重现这个故事，他们真的试了几次——对着鸡蛋碎了之后无法复原的可能性感到困惑。
A few people wrote to talk about how it messed them up as kids to picture Humpty Dumpty left there in pieces on the side of the road, sad look on his face. A woman named Isabella wrote, "I wondered if he had to exist conscious in his cracked state forever or if he would slowly die. Because he seemed to be still alive after he had cracked."
还有几个人写信说，小时候看着矮胖子被留在路边支离破碎、一脸忧伤的样子，这让他们留下了心理阴影。一位叫伊莎贝拉（Isabella）的女士写道：“我一直在想，他是不是必须永远清醒地感受自己破碎的状态，还是会慢慢死去。因为在他碎了之后，他似乎还活着。”
There's something about that image of someone broken so badly that nothing can fix it, that things can go so wrong, the finality of that-- before you understand all the bad things that can happen in the world, how things come apart and people you love can die and you will die, before you get to any of the entropic, messy chaos of our world with its blackened toilets and its long-ago trashed model trains, you get this glimpse, this fat, cartoon, overdressed egg man smashed to tiny bits of shell and goo.
那种被严重破坏以至于无法修复的形象有些东西，事情会变得如此糟糕，那种终极的结局——在你理解世界上所有可能发生的坏事之前，在理解事物是如何分崩离析、你所爱的人会去世、你自己也会死之前，在你接触到我们这个世界充满熵增和混乱的泥潭之前——那些发黑的厕所和很久以前报废的火车模型——你先看到了这个瞥见：那个臃肿、卡通、穿着考究的蛋人被砸成了细小的蛋壳和黏液。
Today on our program, people who hit a moment when things shatter apart-- now they make sense of it and not go to pieces themselves. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天的节目中，我们将讲述那些在事情分崩离析时经历人生时刻的人们——他们如何去理解这一切，而自己没有随之崩溃。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Toy R Us. Sometimes there's a really specific moment when things fall apart, and you know exactly what the moment was, but you were left with no idea how or why it happened or-- more important-- how to put the thing back together. David Kestenbaum found a family that happened to, a father and son, years ago. And the son has thought about it ever since.
第一幕，“玩具反斗城”。有时真的有一个特定的时刻，事情彻底瓦解，你知道那个时刻究竟是什么，但你完全不知道它是如何或为何发生的，或者更重要的是——如何把事情恢复原状。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）发现了一个遇到这种情况的家庭，一对父子，那是多年前的事了。从那以后，儿子就一直记挂着这件事。
The son in this story, his name is Peter Ocko. And I don't usually love hearing people's dreams, but this is how our interview started.
这个故事里的儿子，他的名字叫彼得·奥克（Peter Ocko）。我通常不喜欢听别人的梦，但这确实是我们采访的开场。
Can I tell you my dream last night?
我可以讲讲我昨晚做的梦吗？
Yes. Oh, yeah.
当然。哦，好的。
Because you know I've been sort of worrying about this-- I dreamt that I pulled into a store, ran inside to pick something up. And when I came outside, there was a guy standing there, and he had disassembled my entire car. And the pieces were just all over the parking lot. And I was like what did you do to my car? Why did you take it apart? And he goes, it was broken. We needed to fix it. And then I woke up. And I was like, OK. I'm the car, and you're the guy.
因为你知道我一直为此感到担忧——我梦见我把车开进了一家店，跑进去买点东西。当我出来时，有一个人站在那儿，他已经把我整辆车拆解了。零件散落在整个停车场。我就问，你对我的车做了什么？你为什么要把它拆了？他说，它坏了。我们需要修好它。然后我就醒了。我当时想，好吧。我就是那辆车，而你就是那个人。
I'm happy to be the guy. Let's take the car apart. The whole story starts here. When Peter was a kid, his dad got a kind of dream job. This was in the late '70s.
我很乐意当那个人。让我们把车拆开看看。整个故事从这里开始。彼得还是个孩子时，他父亲得到了一份理想的工作。那是在70年代末。
When I was 11, he got a job at the Milton Bradley Company.
我11岁的时候，他在米尔顿·布拉德利（Milton Bradley）公司找到了一份工作。
Like the toy company.
就是那家玩具公司吗？
Yeah, the toy company-- as a toy inventor.
对，那家玩具公司——担任玩具发明家。
Oh my god.
天哪。
Yeah. Well, that's what I thought too. I was in sixth grade. And this was like, super street cred to go in and say, my dad works at Milton Bradley. Because they were a big deal back then. But they were a big deal for 100 years.
是啊。嗯，我也是这么想的。我当时上六年级。在当时，能说“我爸爸在米尔顿·布拉德利工作”简直太有面子了。因为他们在那时是大牌公司。他们在那之前已经火了100年了。
In fact, my dad moved into his cubicle. And he was next to the guy who claimed to have invented Chutes and Ladders. So [LAUGHS] I don't think that's true, but the guy was old enough that it's possible.
事实上，我父亲搬进了他的隔间。他旁边坐着那个声称发明了“滑梯与梯子”（Chutes and Ladders）的人。所以[笑]我不认为那是真的，但那个人年纪够大，所以也有可能。
The job was exciting for Peter's dad too. His dad had always been searching for a way to be successful. And success was the thing he imagined happening all at once. He saw himself as an inventor. And if he just had the right idea, the world would notice. His ship would come in. He actually read a lot of books about ships and captains.
这份工作对彼得的父亲来说也很让人兴奋。他父亲一直渴望成功。他把成功想象成突如其来发生的事情。他把自己视为发明家。如果他能想到绝佳的点子，全世界都会注意到他。他总觉得自己会迎来人生的转机。他其实读了很多关于船只和船长的书。
Anyway, his previous attempt at conquering the world had not gone so well. He'd created these kind of cardboard models of famous landmarks that he tried to sell as kits.
总之，他之前征服世界的尝试并不太顺利。他做了一些著名地标的纸板模型，试图作为套件出售。
My mom and I and him-- I was an only child. And the three of us would go out to the garage with hairdryers and kind of shrink wrap these cardboard model kits and put them in UPS boxes. And that was our life for a few years. And then it just died. It just died. And so he was struggling because he saw himself as an idea guy. And so when he got the chance to go to Milton Bradley and be a game designer or a toy designer, I think he was super excited.
我和我妈还有他——我是独生子。我们三个会带上吹风机到车库，用热缩膜把这些纸板模型包起来，装进UPS盒子里。这就是我们几年的生活。然后生意就倒闭了。彻底倒闭了。所以他很挣扎，因为他一直把自己看作是“创意人才”。所以当他有机会去米尔顿·布拉德利担任游戏设计师或玩具设计师时，我觉得他超级兴奋。
The one bad thing about the job was that Milton Bradley was 90 miles from where they lived in Massachusetts. So his dad would just work there the whole week, only come home on the weekends.
这份工作唯一不好的一点是，米尔顿·布拉德利离他们在马萨诸塞州的家有90英里远。所以他父亲整个星期都待在那里工作，只有周末才回家。
I was in sixth grade. I hated it. I hated seeing him leave on a Sunday and then return the following week. And it was a long week, and I really missed him. So Fridays, when he pulled into the driveway, I was ecstatic. I just was so happy to see him. And he'd always come home with a box of stuff.
当时我在上六年级。我很讨厌这样。我讨厌看着他周日离开，然后下周才回来。那一周太漫长了，我真的很想他。所以每到周五，当他把车开进车道时，我都会欣喜若狂。我真的太高兴见到他了。而且他总是带一盒东西回家。
And the stuff in that box, it was kind of magical. This was 1977. And in that box were circuit boards and wires. Milton Bradley was making some of the first electronic games. Their big hit was Simon-- basically, an electronic version of Simon Says-- a kind of chunky Frisbee-shaped thing with four big buttons-- red, blue, green, yellow-- that would light up.
盒子里装的东西，简直就像有魔力一样。那是1977年。盒子里装的是电路板和电线。米尔顿·布拉德利当时正在制作第一批电子游戏。他们的大热门是“西蒙”（Simon）——本质上是“西蒙说”的电子版——一种圆滚滚的飞盘状物体，上面有四个大按钮——红、蓝、绿、黄——会发光。
And it made these kind of square wave tones that were really distinctive.
它会发出那种独特的方波音调。
[TWO NOTES PLAY]
[播放两个音符]
It would play a sequence. You'd have to remember it and play it back.
它会播放一段序列。你必须记住它并回放出来。
[NOTE SEQUENCE PLAYS]
[播放音符序列]
[NOTE SEQUENCE PLAYS BACK]
[回放音符序列]
[NOTE SEQUENCE PLAYS]
[播放音符序列]
[NOTE SEQUENCE PLAYS BACK]
[回放音符序列]
OK. Even back then, it was a little boring. I'll be honest. I don't think there were any parents saying, like, I can't get my kid off the Simon. But it did feel like you were holding some object from the future, just to press the buttons and hear these kinds of sounds for the first time. Peter and his dad would sit around in this sort of attic room at this big table and just mess around with this stuff.
好吧。即使在当时，这也有一点无聊。老实说。我不认为当时有家长会说，我没法让我孩子停下玩西蒙。但按下按钮并第一次听到这些声音，感觉确实像你拿着来自未来的物体。彼得和父亲会坐在阁楼房间里，围着大桌子摆弄这些东西。
Opening the toys up for me and seeing the circuit board and understanding that this little circuit board was playing the game of Simon-- I would get in there with a screwdriver, pull it out, and then start playing around with it and changing the resistor here or there. You could make it speed up, and suddenly, it was generating electronic music at high speed and flashing lights. It just felt halfway between technology and magic, you know? And I think, for both of us, that was super exciting, you know.
对我来说，拆开玩具，看到电路板，明白这块小小的电路板在运行西蒙游戏——我会拿着螺丝起子钻进去，把它拆出来，然后开始玩它，修改这里的电阻或那里的零件。你可以让它加速，突然间，它就开始高速生成电子音乐并闪烁灯光。这感觉介于科技和魔法之间，你知道吗？我觉得，对我们俩来说，那都超级令人兴奋。
They'd build little electronic kits together, which could get kind of tense. His dad liked to follow instructions-- Peter, not so much. They'd share little discoveries with each other, like when Peter realized you could take the spring from a ballpoint pen, put it across the terminals of a 9-volt battery and the electricity flowing through it would make it glow, like the filament in a light bulb.
他们会一起组装小型电子套件，这有时会变得有点紧张。他父亲喜欢按说明书做——彼得可不太喜欢。他们会分享彼此的小发现，比如彼得意识到你可以取下圆珠笔里的弹簧，跨接到9伏电池的两端，流过的电流会让它发光，就像灯泡里的灯丝一样。
But more than anything, it was a way to spend time together. Week after week, when his dad would come home, this was their routine. They'd go up to the third floor and just be together, sitting side by side at this big drafting table. And then one day, as Peter thinks he remembers it, a kind of remarkable thing happened in that room, something that changed their lives. It was just Peter there that day in the workshop.
但最重要的是，这是他们共度时光的一种方式。一周又一周，当他父亲回家时，这就是他们的日常。他们会去三楼，肩并肩坐在那张巨大的绘图桌前。然后有一天，据彼得记得，那个房间里发生了一件非同寻常的事，改变了他们一生的事。那天只有彼得在工作室里。
What I remember is he had gone back to work on a Monday morning and left behind a box of stuff. And in that box was a bunch of circuit boards for different things, including a Simon circuit board. And I remember pulling it out and connecting it up to some batteries and just tinkering around with it, playing around with it.
我记得的是，他周一早上回去工作了，留下了一盒东西。盒子里有一堆不同用途的电路板，包括一块西蒙电路板。我记得把它拿出来，连接上电池，然后就开始瞎摆弄，玩弄它。
And then I remember just looking at the lights and thinking, like, well, let me unsolder the lights and see if a motor will work there. Because we had these little hobby motors laying around. So I took off the four lights, and then I connected two motors to where two of the lights had been and tried it again. And the motor spun. When the lights would have lit up, the motor spun. And I was like, that's cool.
然后我记得看着那些灯光，心想，好吧，让我把灯拆下来，看看电机能不能在那个位置工作。因为我们手头有这些小爱好电机。所以我拆下了四个灯，然后在其中两个灯的位置接上了两个电机，又试了一次。电机转了。在灯原本应该亮起的地方，电机转了起来。我当时想，这太酷了。
In his memory, he then had another idea. I wonder if you could use those motors to make the wheels turn on a little car. Then the Simon board would be controlling a car. That would be neat.
在他的记忆里，他随后又有了另一个想法。我在想能不能用这些电机让小车的轮子转动起来。然后西蒙电路板就能控制一辆车了。那一定会很棒。
There was a mode in the Simon game where you could tell it which lights you wanted. You could program the pattern yourself. So I was like, well, you could program left motor, right motor. And so it's like a programmable car.
西蒙游戏里有一个模式，你可以指定你想要的灯光顺序。你可以自己编程。所以我当时想，好吧，你可以编程“左电机，右电机”。所以它就像一辆可编程的小车。
A programmable car. You could punch some buttons on it, tell it you wanted it to drive forward, turn right, drive some more, turn left. Then it would go and do it.
一辆可编程的小车。你可以在上面按几个按钮，告诉它你想要它向前开，右转，再向前，左转。然后它就会真的去执行。
My dad came back on the following Friday, and I was excited to show him this little thing I'd built. And he'd took a look at it. It wasn't like the symphony started playing. He's like, that's really cool. That's a good idea. And I was like, cool. You think I have a good idea. That's awesome.
我父亲接下来的周五回来，我兴奋地给他看了我组装的这个小东西。他看了一眼。并不是像交响乐开始演奏那样。他只是说，这真的太酷了。这是个好主意。我当时想，酷。你认为我有好点子。那太棒了。
His dad brought the idea into work. And Milton Bradley started to develop it as an actual toy with Peter's dad leading the team. His dad would update him when he got home. Like, our little thing is still moving forward. And as it got further along, he'd bring home these kind of handmade prototypes of it. The toy that was taking form was sort of a tank, dump truck kind of thing. You could program it to carry something to a place and drop it off, all on its own.
他父亲把这个点子带回了工作单位。米尔顿·布拉德利开始把它开发成真正的玩具，彼得的父亲负责团队。他父亲回家时会更新进度。比如，我们那个小东西还在继续推进。随着项目深入，他会带回家一些手工制作的原型机。正在形成的那个玩具大约是一辆坦克，又像自卸卡车。你可以给它编程，让它自主地把东西运到某个地方并卸下。
I remember one problem they had was they couldn't get the tank to go perfectly straight. I remember my dad having this eureka moment one day and being like, oh. And he put two magnets opposing each other on the end of the shaft that wasn't on the wheel so that the motors lined up with these magnets and the magnets grabbed each other without actually touching and kept the motors moving at exactly the same speed. It was brilliant.
我记得他们遇到的一个问题是，他们无法让坦克走得完全笔直。我记得有一天我父亲突然灵光一现，他说，噢。他在轴的末端放了两个相对的磁铁，这样电机就与这些磁铁对齐，磁铁在不接触的情况下相互吸引，让电机保持完全相同的速度转动。这太聪明了。
And he had those little victories. Imagine that over a nine-month period, where you just keep figuring it out, and then it works and then it's successful.
他有了那些小小的胜利时刻。想象一下在九个月的时间里，你不断地解决问题，然后它成功了，然后它变得大获成功。
This is Big Trak, the computer-activated truck from MB Electronics. Program in up to 16 commands and Big Trak will advance, turn, and fire three blasts.
这是Big Trak，MB电子推出的计算机激活卡车。输入最多16个指令，Big Trak就会前进、转弯并发射三次冲击。
[FUTURISTIC BLASTING]
[未来主义的爆炸声]
Milton Bradley sold lots of them-- quite a few in Glenside, Pennsylvania, where I grew up. I remember them popping up in friends' houses after Christmas. And those ads were all over TV-- Big Trak rolling across the floor in the suburban living room and delivering an apple to dad.
米尔顿·布拉德利卖了很多——我在长大的格伦赛德（Glenside）宾夕法尼亚州见到了不少。记得圣诞节过后，朋友家里都会出现这些玩具。电视上到处都是那些广告——Big Trak在郊区的客厅地板上滚来滚去，给爸爸送上一个苹果。
Big Trak for your child from MB Electronics. Transporter sold separately.
MB电子送给您孩子的Big Trak。运输车另售。
Sales? Best estimate I was able to find-- $40 million.
销量？我能找到的最佳估算——4000万美元。
This project, it gave Peter's dad the thing he'd been wanting-- a real success. But people are complicated.
这个项目给了彼得父亲他一直渴望的东西——真正的成功。但人是很复杂的。
He was on top of the world. And I know he felt good. He came home and felt good. But that started to sour as he started to realize how much money the company was going to make from this toy.
他当时处于世界之巅。我知道他感觉很好。他回家时感觉很好。但这开始变味了，当他意识到公司能从这个玩具里赚多少钱的时候。
Because this was his ship that was supposed to come in.
因为这就是他本以为会到来的那艘人生之船。
I think he saw it-- at first, I think he was perfectly happy to be seen as the guy in charge of a project within a corporate framework that's doing well. And as the stakes got higher and the calls from his mom-- every Sunday, his mother would call. And she was never satisfied with where he was in life. I think she would have been really happy if he had been a doctor or a lawyer.
我觉得他看待这件事——起初，他对于被视为公司框架下项目负责人的感觉很满足。但随着赌注越来越高，来自他母亲的电话——他母亲每周日都会打电话。她对他生活的现状从来都不满意。我觉得如果他是个医生或律师，她会真的很高兴。
And I think for him, he started to see that he could prove himself with this project. And his self-worth, I think, became really tied up with the success of this project.
而对他来说，他开始意识到他可以通过这个项目证明自己。我想，他的自我价值感开始与这个项目的成功紧密相连。
Peter's dad was frustrated. He had brought this toy into existence. But in the end, it would be the company's success, not his. The toy was a big hit. But it wasn't going to make his dad rich. Peter would overhear his parents talking in the next room, his dad increasingly unhappy. And, realizing there wasn't going to be any glory for him, he quit the dream job.
彼得的父亲很沮丧。他把这个玩具带到了世上。但最终，这是公司的成功，而不是他的。这个玩具大受欢迎。但它没能让他父亲发财。彼得会听到父母在隔壁房间谈话，他父亲越来越不高兴。意识到不会有属于自己的荣誉，他辞去了那份梦想的工作。
He thought about legal action. But, of course, he couldn't sue Milton Bradley for taking his idea. He was an employee, so the company owned everything he created, which is pretty much how it works at any company. But at some point, Peter's dad talks to a lawyer. And one of the things he says to the lawyer is, hey, the whole idea for Big Trak, I didn't come up with that. It actually came from my son, from Peter, who was not a Milton Bradley employee.
他考虑过诉诸法律。但当然，他不能因为米尔顿·布拉德利采用了他的想法而起诉他们。他是员工，所以公司拥有他创造的一切，这在任何公司都是如此。但在某个时候，彼得的父亲咨询了一位律师。他跟律师说的一件事是：嘿，关于Big Trak的整个点子，那不是我想出来的。其实是我儿子彼得想出来的，他不是米尔顿·布拉德利的员工。
Then the lawyer says to him, well, a kid can sue a corporation.
然后律师告诉他，嗯，孩子是可以起诉公司的。
A kid can sue a corporation.
孩子可以起诉公司。
A kid can sue a corporation. And I know this because my mom had kept diaries her whole life. And I found the diary from the time this was all happening. And she had just noted in there, Steve says, lawyer said, a kid can sue a corporation.
孩子可以起诉公司。我知道这一点是因为我妈妈一直有写日记的习惯。我找到了事情发生那段时间的日记。她随手记录道：“史蒂夫说，律师说，孩子可以起诉公司。”
And that is how the lawsuit Peter Ocko, 13-year-old boy, versus the Milton Bradley company came to be. The basis for the lawsuit was that if Peter, the kid, had come up with the initial idea for this multi-million-dollar toy, then he was owed royalties. It could be a lot of money.
这就是后来“13岁男孩彼得·奥克起诉米尔顿·布拉德利公司”一案的由来。诉讼的基础是，如果彼得这个孩子想出了这个数百万美元玩具的原始创意，那么他就应得版税。那可能是一大笔钱。
I asked Peter if the prospect of being a kid suing a giant corporation felt scary. He said not really, though maybe it should have. He said it felt thrilling, kind of awesome. A big, fancy Boston law firm took their case.
我问彼得，作为孩子起诉巨型公司是否感到害怕。他说并不觉得，虽然也许本该如此。他说那感觉很刺激，甚至很酷。一家大型的高端波士顿律师事务所接手了他们的案子。
And that firm decides, we're going to take this case on contingency. We actually think this has a really good chance. And you guys won't have to pay anything but the court costs or the Xerox costs. So at this point, my dad is ecstatic. And we're both ecstatic. I'm now playing a really important role in the both of us getting what's due for this idea.
那家公司决定，我们要风险代理这个案子。我们确实认为胜算很大。你们不需要支付任何费用，只需承担诉讼成本或复印费。所以这时，我父亲欣喜若狂。我们也都很兴奋。我现在在这一过程中扮演了非常重要的角色，为了我们俩争取这个创意应得的东西。
Peter says, looking back, he was just coming into that age where you're really craving some kind of identity. And now he had one, teenage whiz kid.
彼得说，回头看，他当时正处于渴望某种身份认同的年龄。而现在他拥有了一个：少年天才。
I'm just about to go into high school. And, suddenly, I have to take time off from school to go meet with lawyers and give a deposition. And now everybody at my school knows what's going on. And it's really exciting. It's like, I'm at the center of it.
我当时刚要上高中。突然间，我得请假去见律师，接受取证。现在我学校里的每个人都知道发生了什么。这太令人兴奋了。就像我处于事件的中心。
Two years went by of preparation, legal back and forth. And, finally, the court date approached. Peter and his dad would take long walks around the block with the dog, both kind of excited by it all, going over the story he would tell in court. And then there was one night, the night Peter's thought about and puzzled over for years.
两年的筹备、法律交锋过去了。最后，开庭日期临近了。彼得和父亲会带着狗在街区散步，两人都对此感到兴奋，温习着他在法庭上要讲的故事。然后有一个晚上，彼得多年来一直反复回想和困惑的那个晚上。
We had a dinner conversation that changed my life. I'm not trying to be dramatic. I just-- it's like, I look back at the little pieces that had to move into place for this all to go south. And they're so small.
我们发生了一次改变我人生的晚餐谈话。我不是想装得戏剧化。我只是——回头看，那些必须归位的小碎片最终让这一切走向了溃败。它们太微小了。
To understand what happened, you need to know two things. First was that before bringing the lawsuit, Peter's dad had signed a document making it so that, legally, he no longer had financial responsibility for Peter. This was at the recommendation of the lawyers and made it so that, as far as the jury would be concerned, this would be about Peter, not his dad trying to get money through him-- even though it kind of was. It would also help protect any money they won. That's the first thing you need to know. Here's the other thing.
要理解发生了什么，你需要知道两件事。第一是，在提起诉讼前，彼得的父亲签署了一份文件，在法律上让他不再承担对彼得的经济责任。这是律师的建议，这样在陪审团看来，这就是关于彼得个人的案子，而不是他父亲想通过他赚钱——尽管本质上确实是这样。这也将有助于保护他们赢来的任何钱。这是你需要知道的第一件事。还有一件事。
My mother and father didn't have a smooth marriage, and that's an understatement. They fought a lot. By the time I was born-- and, certainly, by the time I was a teenager-- they spent a lot of time and energy trying to upset each other.
我父母的婚姻并不顺遂，这还是保守的说法。他们经常吵架。到我出生时——当然到我十几岁时——他们花了很多时间和精力试图让对方难受。
And if you put that into the soup, along with the fact that my mother now has taken financial control of me and I am the plaintiff in this lawsuit-- we all sit down to dinner soon after that agreement my mom signed. And we're sitting around the table. It's the three of us-- it's a tiny family. We're all sitting there, staring at each other.
如果你把这些放进汤里，再加上我母亲现在已经接管了我的经济控制权，而我是这起诉讼的原告——我们在那份协议签署后坐下来吃饭。我们坐在桌边。只有我们三个——一个微小的家庭。我们坐在那儿，面面相觑。
And my mom says something to the effect of, well, if you win now, Peter, this money will be yours to control. I'm just your guardian, but it's not the family's. It's really yours. And I think she knew exactly what she was saying. She was absolutely using it to get under my dad's skin.
我妈妈说了一句大意是：好吧，如果你现在赢了，彼得，这些钱将由你控制。我只是你的监护人，但这不是家庭的钱。这真的是你的。我想她很清楚自己在说什么。她绝对是用这句话来激怒我父亲。
And my dad was not a drinker. But if he had a beer or two, he would get very grumpy. And he'd had a couple of beers. And he looks at her. And then I-- sort of missing what's going on-- pick it up. And I'm like, yeah, Dad, maybe I'll share the money with you if I win. But it really is-- I am the plaintiff.
而且我父亲不是个爱喝酒的人。但如果他喝了一两杯啤酒，他就会变得非常暴躁。他刚好喝了几杯。他看着她。然后我——有点没明白发生了什么——接过了话茬。我说，是啊，爸爸，如果我赢了，我也许会跟你分钱。但确实是——我才是原告。
And I don't know. I guess if you could see a fuse blow in my father's head, you would have seen it. Because he kind of took a breath. He said, you know, the real truth, Peter, is that I invented Big Trak, not you. I just told you you did it so that we could bring this lawsuit.
我不知道。我想如果你能看到我父亲脑子里那根保险丝烧断的样子，你肯定能看到。因为他深吸了一口气。他说，你知道吗，彼得，真相其实是我发明了Big Trak，不是你。我只是告诉你那是你做的，这样我们才能提起这场诉讼。
And I just remember the bottom falling out. And I don't know. At that moment, to be-- I think I was 14-- and have my dad look at me and say that, it was amazing how easy it was for me to question everything and just feel like everything that had led up to that moment was a bunch of BS. There was something about him staring at me and saying that that I just doubted everything.
我只记得那一刻感觉天塌了。我不知道。在那一刻——我想我当时14岁——看着我父亲跟我说那种话，能让我那么轻易地质疑一切，感觉之前导致那一刻的一切都是一堆胡扯。他盯着我说的那些话，让我对所有事情都产生了怀疑。
Like that moment he remembered, hooking the Simon board up to the motors, when exactly did that happen? Was it really before his dad had started on the project at work? Or was he doing it after his dad began working on Big Trak? Like, maybe what he remembered was him trying to copy the thing his dad was doing.
比如他记得的那一刻，把西蒙电路板连到电机上，那到底是什么时候发生的？是真的在他父亲开始工作项目之前吗？还是在他父亲开始研究Big Trak之后？也许他记得的是他试图模仿父亲正在做的事情。
Also, at this point, this was a family story they had told many times. Maybe it had grown in the telling, and the telling had created its own version in his head. He had all these doubts.
而且到这个地步，这是一个他们讲过很多次的家庭故事。也许在讲述中它不断生长，而讲述本身在他脑海里创造了它自己的版本。他心中充满了怀疑。
I'm not a whiz kid. I've been used. I don't know. It's really hard for me to talk about. I guess what I felt at the moment was outrage because I believed that I had done it-- but also, at the same exact moment, tremendous doubt. I remember going later to my mom that night and being like, what's going on? What do you remember?
我不是什么天才少年。我被利用了。我不知道。这真的很难谈论。我想我那一刻感觉到的是愤怒，因为我相信那是我做的——但同时，也感到了巨大的怀疑。我记得当晚后来去问我妈，到底怎么回事？你记得什么？
And the thing that drove me crazy was, rather than instantly say, like, oh, that's a terrible thing your dad did. Like, he's just in a bad place-- or whatever I would have wished her to say-- instead, she got super vague. And she's like, I don't know what happened.
让我抓狂的是，她没有立刻说：噢，你爸做的事太糟糕了。就像，他只是陷入了困境——或者任何我希望她说的话——相反，她变得非常含糊。她说，我不知道发生了什么。
The court date got closer and closer. His dad had said this confusing and upsetting thing. Peter didn't know what to make of it. And he was all alone with that.
开庭日期越来越近了。他父亲说了那番令人困惑和不安的话。彼得不知道该怎么办。而且他独自承受这一切。
The hardest part about it was there was no third-party grown-up to weigh in and help me. I couldn't tell the lawyer, hey, listen, my dad said this. What do you think? I had to keep that absolutely to myself and move forward. And my dad did the same thing and my mom did the same thing. And we kind of moved on from that dinner conversation as if nothing had happened.
最困难的部分是没有任何第三方大人来介入并帮我。我不能去跟律师说，嘿，听着，我爸说了这个。你觉得呢？我必须把这件事严严实实藏在心里继续前行。我父亲也一样，我母亲也一样。我们像是没发生过什么一样从那次晚餐谈话中走了出来。
I would be in public with my dad. And we would be telling the story of the trial and talking about how excited we were. And he would be smiling with genuine pride at the fact that his kid was the reason he was able to sue the company and we were going to get justice. Like, he was genuinely proud of me in those moments. And then we'd be alone together, and I'd bring up the conversation. He just couldn't talk about it.
我会和父亲出现在公众场合。我们会讲述审判的故事，谈论我们有多兴奋。而他会带着真实的自豪微笑，因为他的孩子是他能够起诉公司的原因，我们将要获得公正。在那些时刻，他确实为我感到骄傲。然后我们单独待在一起，我提起那次对话。他就是没法谈论。
The trial finally happened. His dad, very invested in it, hated the opposing lawyer, saw him as truly evil. Peter says the whole trial, he wasn't really wondering if they would win. He was looking for clues to what his dad had said and what the truth was.
审判终于开始了。他父亲非常投入，讨厌对方律师，认为他是真正的恶魔。彼得说在整个审判过程中，他并没有真的在想会不会赢。他在寻找线索，想知道他父亲说的是什么，真相到底是什么。
Eventually, Peter took the stand and swore on the Bible. He says, at that moment, it was the part of him that believed it swearing the oath. He told the story he remembered at that moment in their little workroom at home. His lawyer had him take apart a Simon with a screwdriver on the stand, pull out the circuit board, which seemed to impress the jury.
最终，彼得走上证人席并在圣经上宣誓。他说，那一刻，是他心中相信真相的那部分在宣誓。他讲述了他在家里那间小屋子里记得的那一刻。律师让他当庭用螺丝起子拆开一个西蒙，取出电路板，这似乎让陪审团印象深刻。
It's worth noting that the trial was around the time the movie WarGames came out. That's the one where a kid saves the world from nuclear catastrophe because he understands the computers controlling the nuclear weapons better than the adults do. Not surprisingly, the press showed up to the trial. The headline writes itself. "Teenager Sues Milton Bradley."
值得一提的是，审判期间刚好是电影《战争游戏》（WarGames）上映的时候。那部电影讲的是一个孩子拯救世界免于核灾难，因为他比成年人更了解控制核武器的计算机。不出所料，媒体出现在审判现场。标题自己就写好了。“少年起诉米尔顿·布拉德利”。
Let's see. "Dedham, Mass-- a 16-year-old high school boy from Brookline claims that the toymaker Milton Bradley company owes him royalties for a robot tank he claims he invented when he was 12."
来看看。“马萨诸塞州戴德姆——一名来自布鲁克林的16岁高中生称，玩具制造商米尔顿·布拉德利公司欠他版税，因为他声称在12岁时发明了一辆机器人坦克。”
Oh my god, that's you.
天哪，那是你。
That's me.
是我。
OK, now read the other headline.
OK，现在看另一个标题。
"Royalties denied to boy who claims toy his idea. A 16-year-old high school student who claimed he invented a toy robot tank at the age of 12 has lost his bid for $2 million in royalties from Milton Bradley company. A Norfolk Superior Court jury decided there was no valid written contract between the toymaker and Peter Ocko, son of Stephen Ocko, who worked until 1978 as a senior game designer for Milton Bradley."
“声称玩具是自己创意的男孩被拒绝版税。一名16岁的高中生声称在12岁时发明了一辆机器人坦克，却在向米尔顿·布拉德利公司索取200万美元版税的诉讼中败诉。诺福克高等法院陪审团裁定，玩具制造商与彼得·奥克（Stephen Ocko之子，1978年前任米尔顿·布拉德利高级游戏设计师）之间不存在有效的书面合同。”
So you guys lost.
所以你们输了。
We did.
我们输了。
What do you remember about that day?
你还记得那天吗？
Ugh, dark day, literally. It was raining.
呃，那是个黑暗的日子，字面意义上的。下着雨。
After the verdict came down, they went out the back of the courthouse to avoid the press, the three of them-- mom, dad, and him. There was a phone booth on the way out.
判决下来后，他们从法院后门走出去躲避记者，他们三个——妈妈、爸爸和我。路上有个电话亭。
And my dad-- because he couldn't wait-- stepped into one and called his mom. And then he came out, and we all just got in the car. We drove home. And we pulled into the driveway. And we got out of the car. And my dad just kind of walked to the porch. And he sat down on the steps. And he just burst into tears. And I'd never really seen him cry before.
我爸爸——因为他迫不及待了——走进电话亭给他妈打了电话。然后他出来，我们都上了车。我们开车回家。进了车道。我们从车上下来。我爸爸只是走到门廊。他坐在台阶上。然后他突然泪流满面。我之前从未真正见过他哭。
Wow.
哇。
And it was hard. But I do remember feeling a weight lifted-- not just that the trial was over and we didn't have to worry about that, but that all the stuff that had swirled around the truth and the real truth and my dad and me-- that we could just move on.
那是很难过的。但我确实记得感到一种重担卸下了——不仅是审判结束了，我们不用担心那个了，而且是所有围绕真相、真正真相、我和我爸之间的问题——我们可以继续前行。
I'm pretty sure this isn't the goal of the US legal system. But losing this case, it made their lives better. Peter says losing saved them from being the worst versions of themselves, freed them from something bad. And, like three programmable cars, everyone was on a new trajectory. His dad turned left. His mom went right. They got divorced. Peter finished high school and moved away to college.
我很确定这不是美国法律体系的目标。但输掉这场官司确实让他们的生活变好了。彼得说，输了使他们避免成为最糟糕的自己，从某种坏事中解脱了出来。就像三辆可编程的小车，每个人都踏上了新的轨道。他父亲向左转。他母亲向右走。他们离婚了。彼得高中毕业，去了大学。
His dad began a whole new life after that where he seemed much more at peace. He remarried, got a degree in education, worked with kids and LEGOs, inventing stuff. But that moment, it really broke something. Peter says there was always a hint of competitiveness between him and his dad. It would come up when they talked about where he might go to college. Was his school better than his dad's? Or when he was little when they'd roughhouse-- they both kind of wanted to win. There was a tinge of aggression to it, he says.
在那之后，他父亲开启了全新的生活，看起来内心平静多了。他再婚了，获得了教育学位，开始和孩子们一起玩乐高，发明东西。但那一刻，确实弄坏了一些东西。彼得说他和父亲之间总有一丝竞争感。当谈到他可能去哪所大学时，这种感觉就会出现。他的学校比他父亲的好吗？或者当他小的时候，他们打闹时——他们俩其实都想赢。他说这其中带有一种攻击性的色彩。
And that night at dinner, it was like it flipped some switch between them. Those moments they used to have hanging around in the workroom, happily tinkering together, those were gone. And what was left was a feeling that they were not exactly on the same team anymore.
而那晚的晚餐就像在他们之间拨动了一个开关。那些他们过去在工作室里一起快乐地摆弄东西的时光消失了。留下的是一种感觉：他们再也不是同一战线的人了。
It was this kind of lingering sense that we had been thrust into something that made us adversaries and competitors, and we never came out of it. And I came to hate that. I hated that when I would achieve something in my life, like get a new job or whatever, I would hesitate telling my dad because it almost seemed to wound him.
这是一种萦绕不散的感觉，我们被推入了一件让我们变成对手和竞争者的事情中，而我们再也没能从中走出来。我讨厌那种感觉。我讨厌当我生活中取得成就，比如找了份新工作什么的，我会犹豫要不要告诉爸爸，因为这似乎会伤害到他。
What we had been through I think had changed both of us and kind of broke something that we never got back. We never got back an empathy.
我想我们经历过的一切改变了我们俩，弄坏了一些我们再也找不回来的东西。我们再也没找回那种同理心。
Peter is pretty sure he knows what the truth is about who came up with the idea for Big Trak. Maybe it was clear at the time. But it was hard to see as a kid-- hard to feel it with confidence, anyway. The truth-- the only thing that really makes sense is-- that Peter had come up with the idea for the toy.
彼得非常确定他知道Big Trak的创意到底归谁。也许当时很清楚。但作为一个孩子很难看清——至少很难自信地感受到。真相——唯一真正说得通的是——彼得确实想出了那个玩具的创意。
In the trial, some of his dad's coworkers testified that he had come into work and said as much. And it was a thing that, as a family, they had talked about before the lawsuit, that this little idea Peter had was being turned into an actual toy and how cool that was. But that night at dinner, it was a hard fact for his father to have thrown in his face. And so he said what he said. His dad's way of moving past it was just to keep moving.
在审判中，他父亲的一些同事出庭作证说，他确实去单位说过这些。而且这是他们作为家庭在诉讼前就谈论过的事，彼得这个小小的创意正在变成一个真正的玩具，那太酷了。但那天晚上晚餐时，这对父亲来说是一个难以面对的残酷事实。所以他说了那番话。他父亲跨过这件事的方式就是不断前行。
Years past. Peter had kids. His dad would come and visit-- really enjoyed being a grandfather.
岁月流逝。彼得有了孩子。他父亲会来看望——真的非常享受当爷爷。
And I remember thinking, like, this is the dad I remember before that trial. Before all of that started, I remember a kind, sharing, open, curious guy. And it was nice to kind of revisit that. But I would occasionally say to him, do you ever want to talk about this? Because I think about it a lot. And the few times I would bring it up, he would just block. He would just say, I don't. I can't. There's nothing to talk about.
我记得我在想，这就是我审判前记得的那个爸爸。在这一切开始前，我记得一个善良、乐于分享、开明、好奇的人。能重温那种感觉真好。但我偶尔会问他：你还想谈谈那件事吗？因为我经常想起它。那几次我提起时，他就会阻断。他只会说：我不谈。我做不到。没什么好谈的。
Why do you think he wouldn't just tell you which was the truth?
你为什么觉得他不告诉你哪个才是真相？
I don't know. Part of me feels that he did something that he was ashamed of and just couldn't talk about that piece of it.
我不知道。我心里觉得他做了一件让他感到羞愧的事，只是无法谈论那部分。
The lawsuit did come up one last time, in a very strange way, almost like the universe was trying to put the pieces back together.
那场诉讼最后还出现过一次，以一种非常奇怪的方式，就像宇宙试图把碎片重新拼凑起来。
After my dad got cancer, he came out a few times to visit. And one of those times, we had a great visit. And I took him to LAX. And it was back when you could go to the gate with people. And I went to the gate with him. And we were sitting at the gate. And I hear this voice across the room. And it's the attorney from Milton Bradley.
我爸爸得癌症后，他来看过我几次。其中一次，我们相处得非常愉快。我带他去洛杉矶国际机场（LAX）。那时候你还可以带人去登机口。我和他一起去了登机口。我们坐在登机口。我听到屋子对面有一个声音。是米尔顿·布拉德利的那位律师。
No way.
不会吧。
And he's standing there with a younger woman-- I'm assuming his daughter. And my dad just tenses up because he sees it, and I see it. And I don't know why. But I just stood up, and I walked over to the guy. And I shake his hand, and I introduce myself. And he's like, oh, Peter, how are you? And I say, oh, I'm fine. My dad's here. And he's like, oh, wonderful.
他正站在那儿，身边还有一个年轻女性——我猜是他女儿。我爸爸看到他立刻变得紧张起来，我也看到了。我不知道为什么。但我只是站起身，走过去找那个人。我跟他握了手，做了自我介绍。他说，噢，彼得，你好吗？我说，我很好。我爸在那儿。他说了句，噢，太棒了。
And he walks with me over to my father. And my father at this point is kind of a deer in the headlights. And I helped my dad stand up. And they shake hands. And I mentioned, I live in Los Angeles. And he says, yeah, my daughter's out here now. And he goes, oh, I always knew you'd be a success, Peter. That's wonderful. And my dad said, yep, I'm really proud of him.
他和我一起走向我父亲。我父亲那一刻像只受惊的鹿一样。我帮我爸站起来。他们握了手。我提到我就住在洛杉矶。他说，对，我女儿现在也在这儿。然后他说道，噢，彼得，我一直都知道你会成功的。那太棒了。我爸说，没错，我真的很为他骄傲。
And then we just sort of said goodbye. And we sat down. And the attorney got called to first class and went on board. And then we sat there and didn't really say much. And then my dad got called on to coach, and off he went. And that was one of the last times I saw him.
然后我们只是道了别。我们坐了下来。那位律师被叫去头等舱登机了。我们坐在那儿，没怎么多说话。然后我爸被叫去登经济舱，他离开了。那是我最后几次见到他中的一次。
The earliest known version of the Humpty Dumpty rhyme, it's not the same as the one you know. It may have been a riddle about an egg, or it may have been a poem about a person. It went like this.
已知的最早版本的矮胖子童谣，和你所知的不太一样。它可能是一个关于蛋的谜语，也可能是一首关于人的诗。它是这样写的：
"Humpty Dumpty sat on a wall. Humpty Dumpty had a great fall. Four-score men and four-score more could not make Humpty Dumpty where he was before--" which I read differently from the one we know. You can put a broken thing back together. It's just going to be different.
“矮胖子坐在墙头上。矮胖子重重地摔了一跤。八十个大汉加八十个，也无法让矮胖子恢复原样——”这和我们所知的版本读起来很不一样。你可以把破碎的东西重新拼在一起。它只是会变得不一样。
David Kestenbaum is our senior editor. Coming up, a man-- not an egg-- falls off a very high wall. And he does not look around for either king's horses or king's men. Imagine that. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们的资深编辑。接下来，一个男人——不是一个蛋——从一堵非常高的墙上摔了下来。他没有指望国王的马或国王的仆人。想象一下。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "All the King's Horses"-- about things broken so badly, they cannot be put back together. We've arrived at act two of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《国王所有的马》——关于那些破碎得太严重、无法恢复原样的东西。我们到达了节目的第二幕。
Act two, The 95. This next story is about somebody examining something very broken, something documented in a list assembled by the Committee to Protect Journalists, of journalists who've been killed in the Israel-Hamas war. It's the largest number of journalists who've died in any conflict since they started counting.
第二幕，“95”。下一个故事是关于某人审视破碎的东西，记录在保护记者委员会（Committee to Protect Journalists）的一份名单中，记录的是在以色列-哈马斯战争中遇难的记者。这是他们开始统计以来，在任何冲突中死亡记者人数最多的一次。
The list gives each person's name, where they worked, circumstances of their death-- sometimes a few more details, but often, that's all. Reporter Dana Ballout has been reading about the people on the list, watching their work, talking to their colleagues, trying to piece together who they were and what was lost when they died. Here she is.
名单列出了每个人的名字、工作单位、死亡经过——有时多几条细节，但通常也就这样。记者达娜·巴鲁特（Dana Ballout）一直在阅读名单上的人，观看他们的作品，采访他们的同事，试图拼凑出他们是谁，以及他们死时失去了什么。她在那儿。
I first started noticing the journalists dying on Instagram. I'm a journalist. I'm Arab. And I've reported on war. A big part of my community is other Arab journalists who do the same thing. And when someone dies, news travels fast.
我最初是在Instagram上注意到记者死亡的消息。我是记者。我是阿拉伯人。我报道过战争。我的社区很大一部分是做同样事情的其他阿拉伯记者。当有人去世，消息传播得很快。
Recently, I pulled up the list that the Committee to Protect Journalists has been keeping and looked at it for the first time. There are 95 journalists and media workers on it as of today. Almost everyone on it is Palestinian. Scrolling through, I started to get angry. These were the people carrying the burden of documenting this whole war.
最近，我调出了保护记者委员会一直在保存的名单，第一次看了看。截至今天，名单上有95名记者和媒体工作者。上面几乎每个人都是巴勒斯坦人。翻阅着，我开始愤怒。这些人承担着记录整场战争的重担。
Israel is not allowing foreign journalists into Gaza, except on rare occasions with military escorts. These people's names are being buried in a giant list that keeps growing. What I want to do is lift some of them off the list for a moment and give you a glimpse of who they were and the work they made.
以色列不允许外国记者进入加沙，除了偶尔有军事护送的特殊情况。这些人的名字正被埋没在一个不断增长的巨大名单里。我想做的是把他们中的一些人从名单上提出来，让你一瞥他们是谁，以及他们创造的作品。
I'll start with Sari Mansour. Sari was the director of Al Quds News Network. And he posted a 22-second video on November 18 that was a report from the war, but it also gave me a picture into his marriage.
先从萨里·曼苏尔（Sari Mansour）开始。萨里是圣城新闻网（Al Quds News Network）的负责人。他在11月18日发了一段22秒的视频，那是一篇关于战争的报道，但也让我看到了他的婚姻生活。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语演讲]
Sari's wearing his press vest and looks exhausted. He's explaining that cell service and the internet keep getting cut off and it's often impossible to text or call anyone, including his wife. So they've resorted to using handwritten letters to communicate while he's out reporting, sending them back and forth with neighbors or colleagues.
萨里穿着他的媒体马甲，看起来筋疲力尽。他解释说手机服务和互联网一直中断，通常不可能发短信或打电话给任何人，包括他的妻子。所以他们不得不诉诸于手写信件来交流，他在外面报道时，通过邻居或同事把信件传回去。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语演讲]
He ends the video with a picture of one of these letters from his wife. In it, she writes, "Me and the kids stayed up waiting for you until the morning, and you didn't come home. We were really sad. I kept telling the kids, look, he's coming. But you didn't show up. May God forgive you.
他以妻子写的一封信的照片结束了视频。信中她写道：“我和孩子们一直等着你等到早上，你没回家。我们真的很难过。我一直在告诉孩子们，看，他要回来了。但你没出现。愿上帝宽恕你。
Come home tomorrow and eat with us. Do you want me to make you kebab or maybe kabseh? Bring your friends with you. It's OK. And give Aziz the battery to charge. What do you think about me sending you handwritten letters with messenger pigeons from now on? Ha, ha, ha. I'm just kidding. I want to curse at you, but we're living in a war. Too bad. OK, I love you. Bye."
明天回来和我们一起吃饭吧。你想让我给你做烤肉串还是卡布萨？带上你的朋友吧。没关系。把电池给阿齐兹（Aziz）充电。你觉得我以后用信鸽给你寄手写信怎么样？哈哈，开玩笑的。我想骂你，但我们正生活在战争中。太遗憾了。好吧，爱你。再见。”
A few hours after he shared that letter, Sari and his coworker, Hassouneh Salim, were at Sari's home when they were killed by an Israeli airstrike that hit his house. His wife and kids, who weren't there, survived.
在他分享那封信几个小时后，萨里和他的同事哈苏内·萨利姆（Hassouneh Salim）在萨里的家中被以色列的空袭炸死。他的妻子和孩子当时不在那里，幸免于难。
Gaza's tiny, and the journalist community is really close. Reading the list, you can see all the connections between people, like with Ibrahim Lafi. Ibrahim was a photo journalist, one of the first journalists to die. He was killed while reporting on October 7. He was just 21, still new to journalism.
加沙很小，记者圈子真的很亲密。读着名单，你可以看到人与人之间的所有联系，比如易卜拉欣·拉菲（Ibrahim Lafi）。易卜拉欣是一名摄影记者，最早死亡的记者之一。他在10月7日报道时遇难。他才21岁，刚入行。
On his Instagram, you can see that in his posts just a few years ago, he was still practicing his photography, taking pictures of coffee cups and flowers. Then he started doing beautiful portraits and action shots. You can really feel him starting to become a journalist.
在他的Instagram上，你可以看到他在几年前的帖子还在练习摄影，拍咖啡杯和花。然后他开始拍美丽的肖像和动作镜头。你真的能感觉到他开始成为一名记者。
Clicking around on Instagram, I found a tribute post about Ibrahim from his coworker, Roshdi Serraj. In this photo, Ibrahim's staring intently at the back of a camera, his face lit up by the light from the viewfinder. He looks so young. The caption reads, "My assistant is gone. Ibrahim is gone."
点击Instagram，我发现了他的同事罗什迪·塞拉杰（Roshdi Serraj）发布的关于易卜拉欣的纪念贴。在这张照片里，易卜拉欣正凝视着相机的背面，他的脸被取景器透出的光照亮。他看起来太年轻了。配文写着：“我的助手走了。易卜拉欣走了。”
Roshdi himself was a beloved journalist and filmmaker. And I know that because he's also on the list. He was killed just two weeks after Ibrahim. I read the tribute post to him too. I saw this over and over again, journalists posting tributes, who were then killed themselves soon after. And a tribute goes up for them. And then the pattern continues.
罗什迪本人也是一位受人爱戴的记者和电影制作人。我知道这一点是因为他也在这份名单上。他在易卜拉欣去世后两周被杀。我也读了他的纪念贴。我一次又一次地看到这种情况，记者发布悼念贴，然后自己不久后也遇难了。然后为他们贴出悼念贴。这种模式一直在持续。
Something else I saw over and over on the list, journalists-- later in the war-- who'd become aware that they could be making their last reports. They'd say it at the beginning of their videos. And those were the hardest to watch, especially when it was true.
我在名单上反复看到的另一件事是，记者——在战争后期——意识到他们可能是在做最后的报道。他们在视频开头就会说。这些视频最难看，尤其是当事实确实如此时。
One video like that was posted by Ayat Khadoura. Ayat was a freelance journalist and video blogger. Her videos before the war covered a wide range, from what I can tell-- interviews about women in politics. She even appeared in a commercial for ketchup-flavored chips. She clearly liked being in front of the camera.
阿亚特·卡杜拉（Ayat Khadoura）发布了一段这样的视频。阿亚特是一名自由记者和视频博主。据我所知，她战前的视频涵盖范围很广——关于女性政治的采访。她甚至出演过番茄酱味薯片的广告。她显然喜欢面对镜头。
Once the war started, Ayat pivoted to covering bombings and food shortages. On November 20, she posted a video report from her home. You can hear the airstrikes hitting very close to where she is. It's scary.
战争一开始，阿亚特就转向了关于轰炸和食品短缺的报道。11月20日，她从家中发布了一段视频报道。你可以听到空袭在离她很近的地方发生。这太可怕了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语演讲]
She's saying, this is likely my last video. Today the occupation forces dropped phosphorus bombs on Beit Lehia area and frightening sound bombs. They dropped letters from the sky ordering everyone to evacuate. Everyone ran into the streets in the craziest way. No one knows where to go.
她说，这很可能是我的最后一段视频。今天占领军在拜特拉希亚（Beit Lehia）地区投下了磷弹和令人恐惧的音爆弹。他们从天空扔下传单，命令所有人撤离。每个人都以最疯狂的方式冲向街头。没人知道该去哪儿。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语演讲]
My family and I are split up. Myself and a few others are still at home, but everyone else has evacuated. They don't know where they're going. The situation is so scary. What's happening is so tough, and may God mercy on us.
我和家人分开了。我和几个人还在家，但其他人都撤离了。他们不知道要去哪儿。局势太可怕了。正在发生的一切太艰难了，愿上帝怜悯我们。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语演讲]
And then she begins to cry and the video stops. She was killed later that day.
然后她开始哭，视频中断。当天晚些时候她被杀害了。
Targeting journalists, in case you didn't know, is a war crime. So far, the Committee to Protect Journalists has found that three of the journalists on the list were explicitly targeted by the IDF, the Israeli military. Investigations by the Washington Post and Reuters, Human Rights Watch, and the United Nations have also raised serious questions in these three cases. And the Committee to Protect Journalists is investigating 10 other killings.
顺便说一句，针对记者是战争罪。到目前为止，保护记者委员会发现名单上的三名记者被以色列国防军明确针对。华盛顿邮报、路透社、人权观察和联合国的调查也在这些案件中提出了严重的质疑。保护记者委员会正在调查其他10起死亡案件。
When we reached out to the IDF for comment, they said, quote, "The IDF has never and will never deliberately target journalists." That's the answer they always give in these situations.
当我们联系以色列国防军寻求置评时，他们说：“以色列国防军从未也绝不会故意针对记者。”这是他们在这种情况下总是给出的答案。
Meanwhile, dozens of seasoned reporters have fled Gaza-- journalists who worked for Al Jazeera, the BBC, the New York Times, the Washington Post, Reuters, Agence France Presse. So many media offices were demolished in Israeli airstrikes that the Committee to Protect Journalists stopped counting. It's not just individual lives that have been destroyed. It's an entire infrastructure.
与此同时，几十名资深记者逃离了加沙——曾为半岛电视台、BBC、纽约时报、华盛顿邮报、路透社、法新社工作的记者。太多的媒体办公室在以色列空袭中被夷为平地，保护记者委员会已经停止统计了。被摧毁的不仅仅是个体的生命。而是整个基础设施。
The name on the list that was hardest for me to look at was Issam Abdallah because I'd crossed paths with him once. Issam was a Lebanese journalist, a video journalist for Reuters for many, many years. He had just won an award for coverage of Ukraine. I'm Lebanese and still report there sometimes. And I'd worked with Issam a couple of summers ago.
名单上最让我难以直视的名字是伊萨姆·阿卜杜拉（Issam Abdallah），因为我曾和他有过一面之缘。伊萨姆是一位黎巴嫩记者，路透社多年的视频记者。他刚刚因为乌克兰的报道获得了一个奖项。我是黎巴嫩人，现在偶尔也会在那里做报道。几年前的夏天我和伊萨姆一起工作过。
He helped me film a sort of random story in Beirut. I was interviewing this entrepreneur who had started a sperm-freezing company after an accident where he spilled a tray of hot coffee on his private area, burning himself. I know-- ridiculous. It was a really silly shoot.
他帮我在贝鲁特拍摄一个随机故事。我当时在采访一位企业家，他在一次事故中把一盘热咖啡洒在私处烧伤后，创办了一家精子冷冻公司。我知道——太荒谬了。那是一次很傻的拍摄。
Right after we said cut and started to wrap, Issam started this whole bit about being in his late 30s, reconsidering his own sperm quality, and everything he now realized he was doing to hurt it. And no one could stop laughing. It was a really good day. That felt good to remember-- and to remember him that way.
在我们说“停”并开始收工后，伊萨姆就开始了整段表演，讲到他在30多岁时重新考虑自己的精子质量，以及他现在意识到自己做的所有伤害它的事情。没人能停止大笑。那真是美好的一天。能记得那一天，并以那种方式记得他，真好。
Issam was killed by the IDF on October 13. His death was one of the three that the Committee to Protect Journalists has identified as a targeted killing. He was fired upon by an Israeli tank while standing in an empty field on the Lebanon-Israel border with a small group of other journalists. Everyone was wearing press vests with cameras out. They were covering the Hezbollah part of this war. A few other journalists were injured in the attack, which was captured on video.
伊萨姆于10月13日被以色列国防军杀害。他的死亡是保护记者委员会认定为针对性杀戮的三起案件之一。当他站在黎巴嫩-以色列边境的一片空地上，和一小群其他记者在一起时，遭到了以色列坦克的射击。每个人都穿着媒体马甲，拿着相机。他们当时正在报道这场战争的真主党部分。袭击中还有几名记者受伤，这被视频拍摄了下来。
The IDF says they were responding to firing from Hezbollah, not targeting the journalists. But multiple investigations, including by Reuters, the United Nations, Amnesty International, and the AFP found no evidence of any firing from the location of the journalist before the IDF shot at them. The journalists in the group and video footage confirmed that there was no military activity near them.
以色列国防军称他们是在回应来自真主党的射击，而不是针对记者。但包括路透社、联合国、国际特赦组织和法新社在内的多项调查发现，在以色列国防军向他们开火前，没有任何证据表明该记者所在地有射击。记者群中的人员和视频画面证实，他们附近没有军事活动。
I'd only met Issam once, barely knew him, but it affected me so much when he died. I know that he understood the risks of his job. But somehow, it still felt so random and unfair that he would be struck down like that, following the rules, wearing his press vest and helmet in a pack of reporters on a sunny day in an open field. I find myself thinking about him all the time.
我只见过伊萨姆一次，几乎不认识他，但他去世时对我影响巨大。我知道他明白这份工作的风险。但不知为何，他被那样击倒，在阳光明媚的日子里，在开阔地带的一群记者中，遵守规则，穿着媒体马甲戴着头盔，依然感觉那么随机和不公。我发现自己无时无刻不在想他。
His last Instagram post was commemorating another journalist, this iconic reporter, Shireen Abu Akleh, who'd been killed by the IDF. When I first saw that post in October, I thought, how ironic. Because a week later, Issam also was killed by the IDF. But then after spending time reading the list, I realized how common this had become.
他最后一条Instagram帖子是在纪念另一位记者，那位标志性的记者希琳·阿布·阿克莱（Shireen Abu Akleh），她之前被以色列国防军杀害。十月份我第一次看到那条帖子时，我想，多讽刺啊。因为一周后，伊萨姆也被以色列国防军杀害了。但在花时间阅读这份名单后，我意识到这种情况已经变得多么普遍。
I still haven't finished going through the list and looking up the people on it. I keep finding things that stick with me, like the funny way this one radio host would cut off a caller who was rambling on for too long, a tweet from reporter Ola Atallah that quoted Sylvia Plath. It read, "What ceremony of words can patch the havoc?"
我还没看完名单并查清上面的人。我不断发现一些让我难忘的东西，比如这个广播主持人切断一个喋喋不休的来电者时的滑稽方式，记者奥拉·阿塔拉（Ola Atallah）引用西尔维娅·普拉斯（Sylvia Plath）的一条推文。它写道：“什么样的词汇仪式能缝补这场浩劫？”
I'm going to keep going down the list even though this radio story is over now, just for myself, my own way of bearing witness, which is, in the end, all that these journalists were trying to do.
即便这个广播故事现在结束了，我还是会继续往下看名单，只是为了我自己，我自己的见证方式，而这，最终，也是这些记者试图做的唯一一件事。
Reporter Dana Ballou is journalist and documentary filmmaker. Her story was produced by Diane Wu.
记者达娜·巴鲁特是一名记者和纪录片制作人。她的故事由戴安·吴（Diane Wu）制作。
["RECORDING 801" BY LINA MAKOUL]
This song is by Lina Makoul, a Palestinian musician it's called "Recording 801."
这首歌由巴勒斯坦音乐人莉娜·马库尔（Lina Makoul）演唱，歌名是“录音801”。
Act 3, A Great Fall. OK, so there are lots of ways to break something. And skateboarding is a pretty good one. David Kestenbaum-- who, of course, you heard earlier in the show-- has been obsessed with this one short video of a skateboarder that he keeps watching over and over.
第三幕，“重重一摔”。好吧，弄坏东西的方法有很多。滑板就是一种很好的方法。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆——当然，你之前节目里听到过的——一直痴迷于这一段他反复观看的滑板选手的短视频。
The skateboarder stands at the top of a ramp. The wall of the ramp goes straight down at first, then curves into a flat section, then up again on the other side. It's like an enormous U. You could easily break something from that height. He leans forward. It's 13 and 1/2 feet down. One other number you should know-- 52. That's how old he is in this video-- 52 years old. It's Tony Hawk trying to land a trick that he used to do all the time when he was younger.
滑板选手站在坡道顶部。坡道墙壁起初垂直向下，然后弯曲成一个平坦部分，再在另一侧向上。它就像一个巨大的U形。从那个高度你很容易摔坏点什么。他向前倾。那是13.5英尺深。你还应该知道的另一个数字——52。这是他在视频中的年龄——52岁。那是托尼·霍克（Tony Hawk），他试图完成一个年轻时经常做的动作。
He goes down the ramp, up the other side, spins in the air and--
他滑下坡道，上到另一侧，在空中旋转，然后——
[CRASH]
[摔落声]
--falls onto his knees. He's wearing pads, slides to the bottom, then climbs the stairs to try again. But same thing.
——摔在膝盖上。他戴着护具，滑到底部，然后爬上楼梯再试。但结果一样。
[CRASH]
[摔落声]
I was never a skateboard kid-- they were too cool for me. I know Tony Hawk is the most famous skateboarder in the world, but I've only gotten into him now that he's over 50. On social media, he writes these funny little scenes from his life, like this one.
我从来不是滑板少年——他们对我来说太酷了。我知道托尼·霍克是世界上最著名的滑板选手，但我是在他50多岁时才开始关注他的。在社交媒体上，他写了生活中一些有趣的片段，比如这个。
Kid at skate park. Are you Tony Hawk? Me-- I am. Him-- no, you're not. OK, I'm not. But are you, for real? I am, for real. I thought you'd look younger. Me too.
滑板公园的孩子问：你是托尼·霍克吗？我回答：我是。他：不，你不是。好吧，我不是。但你真的是吗？我：我真的是。他：我以为你会更年轻。我：我也这么想。
So the trick he was trying to do in this video, it's called an Ollie 540. Basically, you go down the ramp, up the other side of the U, then down again-- that a couple times until you get enough height. Then, through some kind of magic, at, like, 15 feet in the air, you spin one and a half times with the board turning underneath you but without grabbing the board. You don't touch it with your hands. Like, you and the board are just rotating it exactly the same speed. And then somehow, you try to land on your skateboard without breaking any bones.
他在这段视频里尝试做的动作叫“奥利540”（Ollie 540）。基本上，你滑下坡道，上到U形的另一侧，然后再滑下来——重复几次直到获得足够高度。然后，通过某种魔术，在离地15英尺高的地方，你旋转一圈半，滑板在脚下转动但不能抓板。你不能用手触碰滑板。就像你和滑板以完全相同的速度旋转。然后无论如何，你要尝试落在滑板上而不摔断任何骨头。
[CRASH]
[摔落声]
Hip.
“髋部。”
Hip, I think he says there. He's written that the trick has gotten scarier as he's gotten older, just committing to the landing at the end. He wrote, "My willingness to slam unexpectedly into the flat bottom has waned greatly over the last decade."
我想他说了“髋部”。他写道，随着年龄增长，这个动作变得更可怕了，仅仅是完成最后的着陆就很困难。他写道：“在过去十年里，我意外猛摔在平地上的意愿大幅减弱了。”
One of the things I like about this video is it's basically a collection of failures over and over. It's edited so you can't see how many tries, but it's a lot. He looks tired and just so human. After one fall, he sits there on the ground, looks up, and swears.
关于这段视频我喜欢的一点是，它基本上就是一次次失败的集合。经过编辑你看不到尝试了多少次，但非常多。他看起来很累，而且非常人性化。在一次摔倒后，他坐在地上，抬起头，骂了一句。
Fuck.
该死。
The next attempt literally goes sideways. He slides out the end of the ramp and takes out a camera there that's filming.
下一次尝试简直侧着去了。他从坡道末端滑出，撞坏了一个正在拍摄的摄像机。
[CRASH]
[摔落声]
[CLATTERING]
[碰撞声]
Sorry. I broke everything.
抱歉。我把一切都弄坏了。
Shy grin, he checks to see if his finger is OK. Cut to Tony Hawk at the top of the ramp again. Deep breath, skateboard over the void again. Plunges down, up the other side, down, up into the air, around--
带着害羞的微笑，他检查手指是否无碍。镜头切回托尼·霍克再次站在坡道顶部。深呼吸，再次滑向虚空。俯冲而下，上到另一侧，下降，冲向空中，旋转——
Woo-hoo!
喔吼！
--and he lands it. Lets the board go flying, covers his face with his hands, drops to his knees and says this.
——他成功着陆了。滑板飞了出去，他双手捂住脸，跪倒在地，说了这番话。
I'm kind of sad.
我有点难过。
"I'm kind of sad," he says. One of the film crew fist bumps him.
“我有点难过，”他说。摄制组的人员和他碰了碰拳。
Did it! So sick, dude.
做到了！太牛了，伙计。
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
Perfect.
完美。
I'm a little sad.
我有点难过。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That was the last one.
那是最后一次了。
Yeah. I never had much finality to anything, but that definitely was the last one I'll ever do. Fuck it. Happy I made it.
对。我从来没让任何事彻底完结过，但这绝对是我最后一次做这个了。去他的。很高兴我做到了。
It was literally perfect.
简直完美。
Thanks, you guys, for hanging in there with me.
谢谢你们，一直陪着我。
The title of the video when it got posted was "Tony Hawk lands his last ever Ollie 540, aged 52."
视频发布时的标题是“托尼·霍克在52岁时完成了他最后一次奥利540”。
I tear up every time I watch this-- in part, because we're basically the same age. He's one year older. Something happens when you're around 50. You can't do things you used to do because stuff hurts. I used to love to run, really love it. I can't anymore-- four knee surgeries. And walking around, I notice things I didn't used to. So many people with little hitches in their steps, working around some bit of pain in a knee, a hip.
每次看这个我都流泪——部分是因为我们基本同岁。他比我大一岁。50岁左右的时候，有些事情会发生变化。你不能再做以前能做的事了，因为东西会疼。我以前喜欢跑步，真的非常喜欢。但我现在不能了——做了四次膝盖手术。走在路上，我注意到了以前没注意到的事。这么多人走路一瘸一拐，在膝盖或髋部的某种疼痛中挣扎。
I reached out to Tony Hawk back when the video came out. I wanted to talk about it. Apparently, he did not-- declined my interview request. So this is going to be a short story. I'll just say this.
视频刚出的时候我就联系过托尼·霍克。我想聊聊这个。显然他没有——拒绝了我的采访请求。所以这将是一个简短的故事。我只想说这个。
A friend told me recently about a doctor who'd gone to work in a small town, ended up treating a lot of older people. And he noticed that the way it would go is that, first, one thing would go wrong. You'd fix it. Then a different thing would go wrong. You'd fix that. Then two things would go wrong at once and then another. Eventually, enough things would break that that's the end. He also said something else. That's the good version, he said. That's the one you want, the one where you get to keep going long enough that all the parts break.
一位朋友最近告诉我，有个医生去小镇工作，最终治疗了很多老年人。他注意到情况通常是这样的：首先，一件东西会坏。你修好它。然后另一件不同的东西会坏。你再修好那个。然后两件东西同时坏掉，接着是另一件。最终，足够多的东西损坏了，那就是终点。他还说了另一件事。他说，那是好版本，那是你想要的，那种你能够撑得足够久，久到所有零件都坏掉的版本。
David Kestenbaum is still making radio stories at 54. Tony Hawk-- a year after that video-- broke his femur. But after surgeries, he's still skateboarding.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆在54岁时还在制作广播故事。托尼·霍克——那段视频一年后——摔断了股骨。但在手术后，他依然在玩滑板。
["ALL THE KING'S HORSES" BY SAM GELLAR]
Our program was produced today by Phia Bennin and Lilly Sullivan and edited by Laura Starecheski. The people who put together our show today include Bim Adewunmi, Chris Benderev, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Bethel Habte, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Rudy Lee, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Safiyah Riddle, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由菲亚·本宁（Phia Bennin）和莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）制作，劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基（Laura Starecheski）编辑。今天参与制作我们节目的包括：比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）、克里斯·本德雷夫（Chris Benderev）、佐伊·切斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、贝瑟尔·哈布特（Bethel Habte）、凯西·豪利（Cassie Howley）、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯（Valerie Kipnis）、鲁迪·李（Rudy Lee）、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、托宾·洛（Tobin Low）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、萨菲亚·里德尔（Safiyah Riddle）、瑞安·鲁梅里（Ryan Rumery）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-特克斯托（Marisa Robertson-Textor）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, and our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Sam Geller wrote the song that you're hearing right now for this episode.
我们的总编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman），资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是埃马努埃尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。山姆·盖勒（Sam Geller）为这一集创作了你现在听到的这首歌。
Special thanks today to Sherif Mansour, Rushdi Aboualouf, Youmna El Sayed, Anan Quzmar, Raja Abdulrahim, Ahmed Maqadema, Carrie Law, Clayton Law, Howard Politzer, Randi Murray, Karen Glass, James Bennett II, Matthew Snyder, Michelle Cann, and everybody who wrote to us about Humpty Dumpty trauma, including Anne Mostue, Heidi Shin, Brandon Shiflet, Sky Wenhold, Kelly Gartside, Julie Davidson, and Isabella Gower.
今天特别感谢：谢里夫·曼苏尔（Sherif Mansour）、鲁什迪·阿布阿鲁夫（Rushdi Aboualouf）、尤姆娜·埃尔·赛义德（Youmna El Sayed）、阿南·库兹马（Anan Quzmar）、拉贾·阿卜杜勒拉希姆（Raja Abdulrahim）、艾哈迈德·马卡德马（Ahmed Maqadema）、卡里·劳（Carrie Law）、克莱顿·劳（Clayton Law）、霍华德·波利策（Howard Politzer）、兰迪·默里（Randi Murray）、凯伦·格拉斯（Karen Glass）、詹姆斯·本内特二世（James Bennett II）、马修·斯奈德（Matthew Snyder）、米歇尔·坎恩（Michelle Cann），以及所有写信给我们讨论矮胖子心理阴影的人，包括安妮·莫斯图（Anne Mostue）、海蒂·申（Heidi Shin）、布兰登·希夫利特（Brandon Shiflet）、斯凯·温霍尔德（Sky Wenhold）、凯利·加特赛德（Kelly Gartside）、朱莉·戴维森（Julie Davidson）和伊莎贝拉·高尔（Isabella Gower）。
Our website thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream over 800 episodes of our show for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to local public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he has started saying my name so much-- like, at the end of every sentence he says. I told him, Torey people do not usually talk to each other this way. He said--
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听超过800集的节目。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给当地公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，他现在开始提到我的名字太频繁了——就像在他说的每一句话末尾。我告诉他，托雷，人们通常不会那样聊天。他说——
Oh, it happens all the time, Ira.
噢，这种事经常发生，艾拉。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。